[Music]
bodily harm betrayal raggadocio would it
even be an Iron Man movie without a few
particulars From the Ashes captivity
never has a greater Phoenix metaphor
been personified in human history
anyone even Vaguely Familiar with Tony
Stark knows the character suffers from a
massive superiority complex Tony is a
world-changing genius and he is highly
aware of that fact this leads Tony to
believe that he knows better than anyone
else to the frustration of his allies
and the advantage of his enemies that's
why a major plot point in each Iron Man
movie is Tony learning humility the hard
way Tony Begins the first film as an
arrogant and selfish weapons
manufacturer it's only after he is
captured by terrorists that he sees the
destruction caused by his weapons and
vows to stop making them in the second
movie Tony has trouble finding a
solution to his deadly illness Tony
undergoes a reality check realizing that
even his great intelligence is not
enough to rescue him from his condition
instead he has to rely on his father's
help from Beyond the Grave to find a
solution in Iron Man 3 Tony's trademark
arrogance crumbles when a mysterious
terrorist called The Mandarin attacks
him in his own home in broad daylight
Tony is forced to concede he cannot
handle this new threat alone and needs
the help of his friends to defeat the
villain all while keeping a grip on his
PTSD
female love interests in the MCU too
often get the short end of the stick but
Tony's long time love interest Pepper
Potts bucks this trend by being an
important part of the Iron Man films
pepper starts out as Tony's assistant
and the closest thing to a companion he
has in his jet-setting Playboy life
throughout the movie pepper supports
Tony even saving his life at one point
in the second film Tony and pepper are
officially a couple dealing with his
personal illness Tony makes pepper the
head of Stark Industries and she takes
over the entire organization on Tony's
behalf but it's in Iron Man 3 when Tony
needs pepper the most struggling to
control his PTSD following the Battle of
New York Tony leans hard on pepper to
keep him going through his insomnia and
night terrors in the end Peppa once
again personally saves Tony's life when
she also briefly gains superpowers and
helps Tony defeat Aldrich Killian
when Iron Man premiered back in 2008 one
major reason why Tony Stark felt like a
breath of fresh air is that his
characterization was so different from
the popular superhero archetypes of the
day heroes like Spider-Man and Batman
had tortured inner lives with an
unhealthy amount of angst Tony is
refreshingly free of such a mentality
and does not usually suffer from a great
deal of self-doubt in fact Tony is so
convinced of his own personal greatness
that he routinely makes a point of it no
moment exemplifies this better than the
end of the first Iron Man film
I am Iron Man
in the next film Tony frames his
ownership of the Iron Man suit as a win
for America in forming a court convened
against him I have successfully
privatized World Peace
Tony Stark is many things he's a Playboy
a billionaire a philanthropist and a
superhero but before all of that Tony is
at his core an engineer and an inventor
the entire Iron Man Saga Begins because
Tony is captured by terrorists and the
only way to escape is to create a suit
of armor that could get him out of the
situation the first Iron Man suit was
built in a cave from spare parts and
it's a very rough Affair big bulky and
not very fuel efficient after returning
home Tony gets to work creating a better
designed version of the suit which
eventually becomes the iconic red and
gold armor we all fell in love with with
each new movie after that including the
Avengers flicks Tony debuts new versions
of the classic Iron Man suit there's the
emergency suit hidden in a briefcase
from Iron Man 2 there's the army of
autonomous suits from Iron Man 3 there's
the Hulkbuster armor from Avengers Age
of Ultron and infinity war and finally
the nanotech suit that Tony wears in his
battle against Thanos and his army
the Iron Man films are considered the
starting point for the MCU not just
because they were the first movies in
the franchise to receive critical
Acclaim and box office success but also
because many of the plot points from the
Iron Man movies became a staple of the
MCU as a whole for instance Tony's
quippy Nature has come to be shared by
many other Heroes as has the villain has
the same power set as the hero thing
started by Obadiah stain the villain
also tends to be someone whom the hero
has scorned in the past in Iron Man Tony
is so busy working on dismantling his
past as a weapons manufacturer that he
doesn't realize that his actions are
negatively affecting his company's
second in command this leads to the
number two stepping up his efforts to
usurp Tony from the company attempting
to kill Tony in the process in Iron Man
2 Justin Hammer was a weapons
manufacturer who had spent a lifetime
being vested by Tony in their field of
work a rival looking for an opportunity
to one-up Tony by stealing and improving
upon his Iron Man armor design to this
end he recruits Ivan vanco AKA Whiplash
whose family was previously crossed by
Starks finally in Iron Man 3 Aldrich
Killian was a researcher whom Tony had
once dismissed and embarrassed as a
result Killian builds his own company
and dreams of the day he can finally
defeat Tony Stark
if Peppa Potts is the voice of reason
and Tony Stark's life and Jarvis is the
blindly faithful Ally who will do
anything he asks James Roadie Rhodes is
the happy medium on Tony's Inner Circle
Roadie was Tony's friend long before he
became Iron Man and he feels a personal
obligation to look out for his Reckless
comrade even if it means breaking the
rules or angering Tony himself
you're only gonna say this once
get out as a high-ranking member of the
United States Air Force Roadie is often
torn between his duty and his friendship
with Tony in the first Iron Man Rhodey
is forced to hide the fact that it is
Tony inside the Iron Man armor getting
into an impromptu dogfight against a
couple of F-22 Raptors in Iron Man 2
Earth by Tony's increasingly unstable
Behavior Brody is forced to go against
his wishes and confiscate a prototype of
the Iron Man armor turning it over to
the U.S Air Force behind his back then
in Iron Man 3 Rhodey has become a new
superhero named Iron Patriot once again
rhodius forced to work outside the law
when his suit gets controlled by the
villain to assassinate the president as
ordered by all rich Killian this time
Rhodey and Tony both work in secret to
bring down the villain's plan
the world of comic books is roughly
divided into two some Heroes believe in
working within the law others believe in
working outside of it but in the case of
Tony Stark you have a little bit of both
while Tony's Chief priority is making
the world a better safer place he has no
interest in doing so by working
alongside the government at least in the
Iron Man films in the first movie Tony
abruptly shuts down his weapons
manufacturing company that had been
supplying the government with Military
Arms for decades he also tries to keep
his identity as Iron Man a secret before
once again abruptly letting the cat out
of the back then Iron Man 2 deals with
the Fallout of Tony's dramatic
declaration as the government tries to
force him to share the tech behind his
armor finally in Iron Man 3 an inside
job to assassinate the president forces
Tony and Rhodey to fly under the radar
for the greater good ironically Tony
works with the government much better in
The Avengers movies joining Shield
despite his suspicions of their motives
after causing the events of Avengers age
of Ultron Tony signs the sokovia Accords
as a means of atoning for his actions
when Tony Stark was being cast the
studio was resistant to the idea of
Robert Downey Jr playing the role
director John Favreau fought to cast
Downey since he felt that the ACT is
very public struggles with his personal
demons would translate very well to Tony
Stark a character who has historically
struggled with demons of his own and so
each Iron Man movie has an important
side plot wherein Tony must learn to
confront his mistakes in the first movie
Tony finds out the hard way that the
weapons his company manufacture often
wind up in the hands of terrorists this
prompts him to become Iron Man and in
the destruction his company had
indirectly caused in the second movie
Tony's habit of not playing well with
others comes back to bite him when his
incompetent rival works with the US
government to create new versions of the
Iron Man armor finally in Iron Man 3
Tony's refusal to get help for his PTSD
and is distancing himself from those
seeking to help him lead to severe and
debilitating breakdowns Tony also gets
his butt handed to him by the villain
when he tries to deal with the Mandarin
on his own in the end Tony only manages
to win after working with rhodie and
pepper to bring down Aldrich Killian on
his own Tony Stark can be a pretty
impossible character to root for a
self-described genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist Tony combines
extreme intelligence with extreme
arrogance and snark he can be hard for
General audiences to like let alone
actively support especially if we don't
get to see Tony in a vulnerable position
from time to time a bit odd
if this was your last
birthday party you're ever gonna have
how would you celebrate it so offset is
many many advantages in life every Iron
Man movie has a major plot point about
Tony struggling with a life-threatening
condition in the first movie Tony gets
severely injured in an explosion and the
only way to keep him alive is through a
miniaturized Arc Reactor that he invents
in places in his chest in Iron Man 2 it
is revealed that the Arc Reactor has
started to poison his entire body once
again Tony races against time to find a
cure for his condition before the poison
can shut down his body in the final film
Tony suffers from PTSD which leaves him
a quivering mess and leads him to make
mistakes that almost get him killed in
this way each Iron Man movie combines
Tony's external struggle against a
physical villain with an internal
struggle against his mortality
while Tony Stark is a very very smart
man something he will personally tell
you if you let him his intelligence does
not always translate to a complete
awareness of his surroundings this leads
to a recurring problem where Tony does
not realize there is a mole in his
trusted Circle working against his
interest in the first Iron Man the mole
is Obadiah stain who is secretly working
to steal Tony's inventions and
eventually kill him off in the second
movie Shield sends Natasha Romanov AKA
Black Widow undercover inside Tony's
company to assess his personality as a
Prelude to asking Tony to join the
Avengers Initiative in Iron Man 3 Tony
has to deal with Maya Hansen a former
love interest who comes back into his
life with details about a radical new
medical procedure called extremis
unbeknownst to Tony Maya is secretly
working with Aldrich Killian to turn
extremists into a weapon while Maya
comes to regret her association with
Killian and tries to help Tony Escape
her actions lead to a great deal of harm
being inflicted upon the world
superhero movies generally tend to keep
the villains in the same country as the
Hero guys like Batman and Superman fight
Americans or they fight aliens but the
Iron Man trilogy specifically deals with
foreign terrorists reflecting on Tony
Stark's past as a weapons manufacturer
in the first movie Tony is captured by a
terrorist group in war-torn Afghanistan
the group makes a return later in the
movie when they are shown to be working
alongside Obadiah stain in the second
movie we get Russian criminal and
international terrorist Ivan vanco AKA
Whiplash who nurses a personal grudge
against Tony vanco builds his own robot
terrorist Army after hijacking the
knockoff Iron Man suits built by Justin
Hammer then in Iron Man 3 Tony has to
deal with his greatest enemy from the
comics the Mandarin the film's version
of the character is depicted as the head
of a massive international criminal
organization called the 10 ranks who
have no problem carrying out attacks on
American soil Tony finds out this
terrorist leader version of The Mandarin
was just an actor set up Killian this
version of The Mandarin was laid a
retconned in Shang chi in the legend of
the ten rings
host credit scenes have become an
expectation for every Marvel movie but
when the original Iron Man debuted the
concept of a post-credits scene was
pretty groundbreaking these punctuative
teasers became Staples of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe hinting at the next
expansion or returning character Iron
Man has probably the most iconic
post-credits scene of all time in the
MCU after many months of speculation
fans cheered at the end of Iron Man when
Samuel L Jackson steps out of the
shadows as Nick Fury and tells Tony
Stark about the Avengers Initiative Iron
Man 2's post-credits scene reveals
Thor's hammer sticking out of a crater
signaling the near arrival of the God of
Thunder Iron Man 3 takes a more
easy-going approach with Tony Stark
having an impromptu therapy session with
Bruce Banner you're actively napping I I
was I I drifted where did I lose you
after three movies worth of Drama we'd
say Tony earned the right to take it
easy this time around
[Music]